More than 100 days of war and the battles
are intensifying.
Ukraine’s losses have been severe.
Since invading, Russia has occupied a fifth
of the country and is pounding the eastern
Donbas - which it seems determined to occupy.
How long can Kyiv rely on western arms and
ammunition?
Who can it really trust?
My guest this week from Brussels is Liubov
Tsybulska, adviser to Ukraine’s armed forces.
Along with her government she's been angered
by President Macron's phone calls with Vladimir
Putin and his warning not to humiliate the
Russians.
It's not diplomacy to call the war criminal
It's not diplomacy after everything what Russia,
Russian forces committed in Ukraine.
So I do not think that calling or suggesting
not to humiliate Putin is an option at all.
So does Ukraine fear western sell-out – or
a deal being done behind its back?
Just how critical is the military situation
and do Ukrainians still believe in the ultimate
victory that President Zelenskiy is promising?
And when the guns fall silent will Russia
ever be held to account for the lives it’s
taken and the country it’s broken?
All that and more on Conflict Zone.
INTERVIEW
Liubov Tsybulska, welcome to Conflict Zone.
Thank you for having me.
After more than 100 days of fighting, your
president is as determined as ever to secure
victory.
The only question, he says, is how much your
people will have to pay for it, to pay for
their freedom.
How much more are you and the people of Ukraine
prepared to pay for that freedom?
You know, freedom is the highest value for
us and we are ready to pay as much as it's
needed, especially after all losses, after
all casualties, after all destructions Russia
brought to our land.
So now there is no question about peace or
surrendering.
And I must say that there is no even the word
peace in our internal discussion.
We talk about victory.
For us, it's very important to win this war,
especially again, after all those thousands
of people put their lives, sacrificed their
lives for our independence and our freedom.
What would that victory look like to you?
First of all, we would like to get back our
territories.
Our first step should be get back to the territories
before [the] 24th of February, and then we
would be ready to talk and have a diplomatic
discussion on how we would regain control
on occupied territories since 2014.
But also, I think for many Ukrainians, it's
very important to get reparations from Russia.
But also, it's very important for us basically
to bring to the Russian people the knowledge
that they were wrong, that this war is...
like nobody wants to be under the Russian
rule in Ukraine, and we want Russian people
to understand this.
Otherwise, if we do not change the regime
and we do not change the perception of the
war among Russian society, otherwise we will
have this conflict and the war again and again.
Russia will repeat it over and over again.
So I think that it's very important for all
of us to make everything possible so Russian
people could go through some reeducation and
reconsidering what they have been done in
Ukraine.
You want them to bring about regime change,
do you?
Is that what you're pushing them towards?
You want them to bring about regime change.
Yeah?
Yes, of course.
Yes.
We would like them to do their homework and
get rid of the dictator.
But the problem is that the majority of Russian
people support the regime, support the war.
And we've been, I mean, we Ukrainians, we've
been warning the West about very dangerous
processes within Russian society for years.
Now we see that this Leviathan, you know,
this monster, has grown up next to us with
extremely nationalistic, extremely chauvinistic
racist views.
And we have to do something with this.
Ukraine has lost, by your government's own
admission, a fifth of your country.
Up to 100 soldiers are being killed every
day, some 500 wounded.
What has that done to morale?
Morale among the people?
You know, for us, of course, it's very devastating.
It's... involves a lot of pain, this whole
tragedy.
But at the same time, we, it's, this war,
it's about our survival.
We do not have other territories we can just
go and occupy.
This is our land.
This is our home.
So the morale is pretty high because we know
what we are fighting for and we know what
Russia brings to those territories it occupies,
like now in Kherson region, when people where
people are being tortured and killed and raped.
So I would say, I would say that morale is
pretty high within Ukrainian society.
The battles in the East are pretty intense
at the moment.
The shelling is unremitting and merciless.
In your view, how critical is the situation
right now?
How vital is it for you to hold on, for instance,
to the eastern city of Sevierodonetsk?
It is important because if they take these
territories, it would give them opportunity
to go further.
And of course, they are not going to stop
only on Donbas.
They would go to Odesa, they would go to Kharkiv
again and there is a high risk then they will
attack Kyiv as well.
And again, like, I think it's also crucial
to understand how this war looks like.
Like it is very, you know, conventional positional
war.
It's basically brings us in its manner to
not even Second World War, but the first one.
Basically it's trenches warfare where artillery
plays the major roles and killing thousands
of people.
So for us, it's crucial to keep the attention
of the West on what is going on in the east.
We keep saying, do not give up.
Keep your interest.
Keep your focus on Ukraine.
Don't think that it's some regional conflict
you can easily ignore, as it used to be like
a few years ago.
So for us, we don't, we want to prevent this
Western fatigue.
If the war goes on for a prolonged period,
do you trust America and Europe to keep supplying
you?
Yes, we do trust.
We trust our partners and we do our best to
engage more partners and get more support
precisely from Central European countries,
especially those who are now expressing some
ideas on surrendering.
We do not accept these ideas.
What President Macron has said about preserving
Putin's, saving Putin's face, or giving conceding
territories, it's not an option for us.
As I said, it's a matter of our survival.
So... and all polling shows that Ukrainians
don't want to live under the Russian rule.
Macron's comments have clearly angered your
government.
Your foreign minister said "calls to avoid
humiliation of Russians can only humiliate
France and every other country that would
call for it.
Russia humiliates itself."
Do you get the impression that the West and
maybe France, Germany or Italy, those who've
been pushing hardest for a ceasefire, are
actually conducting negotiations behind your
back without your agreement?
Or do you fear that they might be?
I don't think this impression that they are
doing something behind our backs, but I think
that they still want to propose it as diplomacy,
which it's not.
It's not diplomacy to call the war criminal.
It's not diplomacy after everything what Russia,
Russian forces committed in Ukraine.
So I do not think that calling or suggesting
not to humiliate Putin is an option at all.
Like, it's not going to help either Ukrainian
people or Western people as well.
And again, like we see clearly that there
is a crisis of values, which is very dangerous
for the Western society as well, because if
these values turn [out] to be only declarative
and if they are not followed by actions, then
it's very easy to use this by totalitarian
regimes.
You know, if we are so vulnerable, if everything
that we fought for and believed in is not
important anymore.
So, yes, we, we — when I say we, I mean
the West — created so many institutions,
you know, said so many words on liberal values
and democracy.
And now we see that, yeah, these values are
not followed with some very concrete actions.
And this is, of course, very demoralizing
for Ukrainians and I believe for many Westerners
as well.
But you've been quite angry with the West.
You tweeted a few days ago: "Every time you
want to bring us together, every time you
want to decide for us, ask us.
This simple rule would help many Western politicians
not to look like imperialist idiots."
Tough words.
Who were you talking about?
I was talking about those officials who are
suggesting us to, to have peace negotiations
right now with Russia, who suggest us to concede
territories and who try to show that there
is a brotherhood between Ukraine and, and
Russia.
Which is not true.
There's a condition attached to the aid, the
military weapons that you're, you're being
given.
You can only shoot at the Russians who are
on your territory.
You can't shoot back at them.
They can destroy your towns and cities, but
you can't touch theirs.
Do you accept that condition willingly?
And will there come a time when you won't
accept it?
I think that the most important for us is
to repel Russian forces from our territories
and we do everything possible.
There are so many Russian troops currently
in Ukraine.
Yes, they do have very low morale because
we, we hear their interceptions, we hear their
calls, what they're saying to their relatives.
We see that they are not motivated at all.
So our main goal right now is to get rid of
Russian troops on the Ukrainian land.
And then we will see.
But my point is that you are fighting in a
way with one hand tied behind your back, fighting
against a nuclear superpower with one of the
largest armed forces in the world.
And the West seems to have gone along with
this idea that they can hit you, but you can't
hit them across the border.
Are you happy with that?
I am not happy and I think that you will not
find even one single Ukrainian who would be
happy with this, that we always have so many
conditions, you know, tying our hands, basically.
And again, let's recall what the West, Western,
some of Western politicians were saying just
three months ago, that Ukraine will would
collapse in three days.
But it's 104 days of resistance.
And we stand firmly.
Have the Americans told you what their endgame
is, how they see this war going, how long
they see it going?
Does it worry you that the one thing that
Joe Biden hasn't talked about is victory,
your victory?
I do not have any, I didn't have any negotiations
on this with Americans.
I just keep hearing a lot of different versions,
how long it might take.
And many people are inclined to think that
it's going to take maybe a year or so.
But I would suggest to the US and other Western
countries to finally believe in us.
That's what we are doing right now.
We are proving that we are capable of winning.
And also there is another topic for discussion:
what we will do, what the world will do, with
Russia, if Russia will lose this war.
And I think it's important to see this, this
possible solution — that Russia will be
weaker and maybe smaller or even maybe collapsed.
So, yeah, I think that it's, it's important
to bring this topic on the table finally.
We don't want to prove every time that we
can win.
We proved it already.
We just need support.
Ukrainian people are not asking to fight for
them.
As our government stated many times, give
us weapons and we will handle the rest.
So we need more sanctions and more weapons
and we will do the rest.
Before we leave the question of Western divisions,
I just want to make the point that perhaps
Putin will attempt, of course, to exploit
those divisions as best he can.
But isn't there a danger in your eyes, in
any case, that the longer the war drags on,
the more those countries who are supplying
your weapons and financing your defense will
want a say in how this conflict comes to an
end, even if they promise, as they have, that
they will respect your decisions, whatever
they are.
Isn't there that danger?
Absolutely.
The danger is there.
And of course, it's in Putin's interest to
sort of freeze this conflict, because then
the West definitely will have this fatigue.
And, you know, voters in different countries,
people in different countries will ask their
governments why they're paying high prices
for gas and oil, for instance, or why we,
we give so much money to Ukraine.
So, of course, it is very dangerous.
But again, like, if we are not giving up,
we ask you not to give up as well.
And do you fear a time when the West...
We are paying...
Do you fear a time when the West might give
up?
Some countries, yes.
But again, like, it's crucial to understand
that we are fighting not only for our land,
not only for our territory, but also for the
values.
And these values are shared with the Western
countries.
And in some, at some point, we are fighting
for the West as well.
And I think that if Russia finishes with us,
it will move further, it will move on.
And the Russian propaganda machine, propaganda
people and Russian officials stated it a lot
of times.
If you look what they are saying, you will
see that they are absolutely very aggressive
towards other countries like Baltic states
or Poland.
So, but I also think that they will have to
kill all of us, like all 40 million people,
to occupy us.
You talked about propaganda.
I want to look at this area because this is
something that you've specialized in.
How would you rate Ukraine's performance on
the digital battlefield as opposed to the
military one?
Ukrainian — I think that Ukrainian information
warriors, as we call them, are very successful.
They are very united.
I think it's the first time when all key actors
in this area — government, civil society
and media — are extremely united, united
in their narratives and in countering disinformation.
It was not like they're back in 2014, back
in 2015.
Now it's changed.
And a lot of people, and I keep hearing it
from many colleagues, many European colleagues,
that "how come that your strategic communications
is so good?"
It's just because the whole society is involved
in communication and we see a great communication
coming from military, from NGOs, from the
government, presidential office, first of
all, the MFA.
So it altogether gives this, this impression
that, yeah, we are winning.
And I think that we really won this first
phase at least of the information war.
You say that.
But your government had to learn some lessons
early on that using fake footage and creating
myths that don't add up, that doesn't always
help your cause, does it?
I'm thinking of the so-called Ghost of Kyiv
story, the Ukrainian pilot who was supposed
to have shot down six Russian fighters in
the first day and a further 40 later on.
Your Air Force command had to step in and
ask Ukrainians, as they put it, "not to neglect
the basic rules of information hygiene."
Has that been respected since then, those
rules?
First of all, I think that it's not right
to use disinformation.
This is very important.
And I think that generally if we look at how
Russia, how Ukraine communicates, I think
we are pretty successfully follow this rule.
There are some exceptions, though, and internally
we have these discussions and believe me,
our government is showing that they are capable
of having lessons learned.
And they have, the Ministry of Defense has
learned one as well.
I mean, they put out pictures of an aerial
dogfight saying it was a MiG-29 of the Air
Force destroying the Su-35 of the Russian
occupiers.
Turned out it was from a digital simulation
game.
Again, that's counterproductive, isn't it?
It is.
But as far as I know, they removed that video
and you can imagine how many people are involved
in communication, some of them are making
mistakes.
It happens.
And the most important part is that they removed
it and they acknowledge that.
What do you imagine could possibly persuade
Russia to give up the territory it's already
taken, or it's taken since February the 24th?
I think that something might be, should be
changed in Russia, first of all, so it could
pull their forces back.
But also the situation on the ground, like
military situation, if they lose a lot of
troops and if their military, if their soldiers
refuse to carry out orders, then of course,
[it] would be a very clear signal to this
local Russian administration, administrations
that they should give up.
But they're as determined to win victory as
you are.
They show no sign of wilting or changing their
mind about that or being ready for compromises.
There's no sign either that...
I think it's mostly...
...anybody else that's standing in the wings,
even if Putin were no longer there, that anybody
different would emerge, anybody with different
policies would emerge.
Yeah.
But back three months ago, they were claiming
that they were going to take Kyiv.
And they failed.
So I think it's mostly posturing.
And we, as I said, we listen to Russian soldiers'
conversations with their relatives interceptions,
and we see that the morale is very low there.
And they do not see why they should fight
for, for what they are fighting.
They do not see the strategic goal.
And they, again, like, they were told, these
soldiers were told that people in Ukraine
would greet them with flowers.
And instead now they come and see that people,
everybody hates them.
Everybody hates them in Ukraine.
Nobody wants to accept Russian army or Russian
administrations or Russia itself.
So I think it's just posturing and bluffing
mostly.
So if they, if they are, suffering with big
losses within their military, then of course,
they will withdraw their forces from the occupied
territories.
Do you still see a future for Ukraine in the
European Union?
Of course.
Yeah.
And majority of Ukrainians, they are willing
to join the European Union and NATO.
And this is very important, this factor, which
shouldn't be excluded — the wish, the will
of Ukrainian people.
And now we see that Ukrainians express their
wish to join the EU.
How discouraging is it for you...
...and bascially come back to the European
family.
How discouraging is it for you?
How discouraging is it for you when a French
minister, Clement Beaune, said last month
that Ukraine might have to wait between 15
and 20 years to join the EU?
Is that typical of some of the mixed signals
that you're getting from Western countries?
Very often these people are the same people
who were saying that Ukraine will collapse
in three days.
Back three months ago.
So I agree it is very demoralizing, but it
is changing and I think it's very important
for our partners and allies in the West to
show this coalition and to strengthen Ukrainian
voice.
There'll always be some politicians who would
express something like this, either in Germany
or Hungary or France.
But again, like, it's crucial to understand
what Ukrainians are fighting for.
And Ukrainians are fighting for democratic
values.
And Ukrainians are trying to disrupt and to
break this extremely bloody and authoritarian
regime in Russia, which would be beneficial
for, for all Western countries.
As I said, when they finish with us, they
will go further and let's not stop them somewhere
in Poland or Czech Republic.
Let's let's stop Russians in the east of Ukraine.
Liubov Tsybulska, it's been very good to have
you on Conflict Zone.
Thank you very much indeed.
Thank you.